yeah welcome to this video playing stin
maybe from Turkey and puts defense
playing that for line III as an old
favorite of mine the idea is to prevent
c5 queen a 5 or this make it more
difficult to play okay he's ignoring all
that and i'm not sure if d5 is great but
like is intending to play evironment
always have a hard time to play this
position with them with like going 45
like to have some sort of normal looking
position this almost looks like a
default position so I'm feeling at home
a bit more want this bishop so it's got
a bishop on g7 but it bites on c3 I have
some ideas on the file and I have got
two bishops hmm
yeah I young
of course if I take windey 60 gets it
back but I wonder about rook be one if I
should rather play something like that
probably channel v I need to do this the
same so you will take against get this
out of the way and use the e-file yeah
the queen is nicely placed really and
they're always this pressure on be too
so my ideas Bishop e3 f2h for this kind
of maneuver covering be two from the
side he probably can play with like
thirty five or six but i am not too sure
about that
maybe just Roxy 8
oh wait maybe co-ed one could have been
an idea I don't think this helps much ah
look a five this is this idea I should
have thought a bit more about that okay
not much that you can do I can I always
have this counter the check only seven
so
so G 40 50 is this is this stupid hmm
should I cover d5 I could do that yeah
why not let's let's keep it protected
for a move and maybe I can play em I can
improve the position oh yeah a bit more
look II fought before stuff like that oh
yeah rookie for him I can do that rock
t5 rock d525 rookie 7s and neat trick
k he spotted that
twinsies form attending Queen a bishop
age four
hmm
yeah I can probably just take it well I
really played this like a [ __ ]
ya can just take the 544 not much just
drooped xt5 not quite sure what he's
thinking about something even better to
know why shouldn't you take
I have no idea why I didn't take a
simple and good now I'm attacking you
seven you can of course take you five no
doesn't yeah I have no idea what he's
doing take here here
how to play this maybe even here lookie
tools my idea
gettin gettin ye 70 we're taking be
seven sound takes okay I need to get you
to journey to covered so it's probably
ang aking endgame that's about equal at
least I'm not losing on time what check
this is a rock edge to meet self-made
cannot prevent it rook edge to meet f5
was bad anyway because he needed to
retreat then black resigned yeah he says
to me lucky Jim I don't know yeah of
course this is not not winning for white
butt white wasn't i wasn't worse or
anything he still needs to be precise
iam not play any nonsense moves rook g5
something it's it's about equal it's not
simply not much to invent here I am I'm
pretty surprised that I couldn't get
anything going here of course the the
main point was I don't I didn't
understand why it didn't take here what
was I don't think there was any any big
thing my computer also just sees nothing
and gives black about a one-pound
advantage it's upon and I have no idea
why I didn't do that here I don't know
it's it's it's about the way it should
be ok happen not much going on alright
thanks for watching